i i don't think i've ever got addicted
to a game that much that i wanted to 100
percent it um no way
because i think the closest i've come
actually um surprisingly is tales of a
rise like
which was which was last year oh oh [ __ ]
it's the first time where i actually
did the fishing mini game because you
know how every game has a fishing mini
game i was like what what is the f who's
[ __ ] what [ __ ] loser plays the
fishing mini game yeah and i'm like this
is actually pretty [ __ ] damn fun
collecting all the fish um but yeah i
mean recently i've been playing horizon
forbidden west i'm like the one [ __ ]
person because everyone's playing elden
ring right now i'm like i'll get to
eldon ring eventually after i finish
horizon forbidden west um
and yeah i mean it's is there a fishing
mini game in that one as well
i don't think there is
i was like oh my god i wish the official
ring i think so i'm i don't know
we're not like dark souls or like souls
born how do you think that's fishing
yeah in an ideal world
we need a twitter account to be like yes
you can fish in hilton freedom i feel
like it's just every jrpg right there
you can fish yeah yeah
it's like a staple i don't know how why
did i become a trope why because because
japanese people love fishing yeah do
they they love fish
okay they love eating fish that doesn't
matter they're like catching it though
yeah a nation of fishermen
by this by the same logic should we ask
brits should you love fishing because uh
we're we're [ __ ] island nation as
well right
[ __ ] we don't eat fish we're [ __ ]
idiots
you got fish and chips that's it we eat
cod we won fish and like salmon if
you're rich
yeah why is that why is that not only
why is there a fishing minigame in every
jrpg but why isn't that 99 of them have
no effect on the main story whatsoever
it'd be pretty [ __ ] if you're fighting
sephiroth and you're about to fight him
and he's like sorry you haven't
collected all of the 19 different
species of fish you are not ready to
face me it's like well get one i guess i
guess that would be weird i think i
would i want a jrpg where you're
actually rewarded
at the final boss if you're like the mob
is like you've you've done the fishing
mini game
how did you know that sea bream scales
were my weakness
they start with like half health
oh where's my health bar going but i
know some people who are like deadly
addicted to like every fishing mini game
in jrpgs i mean alan is that guy alan is
that guy who boots up final fantasy and
then he spends like the first 10 hours
on the fishing mini game and then after
he gets bored of that then he actually
goes play the game allen's like alan's
that guy who actually does the mahjong
minigame in yakuza
because let's be real every yakuza
player is like don't mess with us we
don't know how to play mahjong because
no one [ __ ] does that i mean he came
into the arkansas games
well isn't like the mini games the main
game in
yeah except the mahjong minigame because
no one knows how to follow that's what
that is until you come along and play
and then i'm like let me show you let me
show you how to do it yeah how's your
mahjong coming along jerry really good
my addiction is growing you're speed
running old asian man yeah i am i am i i
went to a mahjong paula for the first
time the other day um
it's really [ __ ] fun i mean like you
know i think that the the general like
stereotype of like a major parlor is
like it's [ __ ] dark it's you know
like smoke is everywhere like basically
the [ __ ] akagi right yeah yeah yeah
but like i walk in and there's i've
never seen that many lights on in one
room like i came in i was like oh [ __ ]
it's so bright and like no one's smoking
in there like a lot of really young
people as well like there was maybe like
two tables that had you know older
gentlemen and everyone else was like
around our age was it all men
no surprisingly like half of them i'd
say like half maybe 40 were were ladies
there were like a couple of tables where
was just four ladies just like sitting
around right um but yeah i went in uh my
i went with like one of my childhood
friends uh because he's been getting
into mahjong as well and he was like oh
we're gonna go to this one uh in ebisu
yeah and i was like why this one in
particular and he's like all the the the
fried rice here is [ __ ] lit
and i was like so we're gonna go play
mahjong are we gonna go for the fried
rice with the yeah you can order food
there and dude to be honest probably
some of the best fried rice i've had wow
in japan nice while playing mahjong i
believe it it feels like the kind of
place where you get a weirdly good meal
yeah well i wonder where did marjon get
this image of it being like a game for
old guys or old people because it's
always old people playing it on like the
street like betting
normally is it i never see that like
normally like my my entire
my entire image of mahjong comes from
media basically because i've before like
before moving to japan i'd never i guess
i'd never seen
anyone play mahjong i i know you're
getting this right pov you're watching a
movie right it's a spy movie let's say a
spy movie or any kind of movie
they're undercover in uh
uh indonesia let's say yeah what did
they
you know let's say they're in indonesia
on a mission yeah oh no their cover's
been blown we've got to start running
through buildings yeah charging the one
building oh it's a it's a food store
chicken everywhere run into the next
room oh god it's a bunch of old people
playing
you've seen this scene like 500 times
every year like because it's always just
old people in a smoky room playing
mahjong every job when they like bust
through the thing and like they keep
running through it's always there always
and then they always do some kind of
corny one liner right as they're running
out here well it's either that or it's
like an old like distinct asian shouting
yeah it's almost like an old kung fu
movie yeah yeah and you you get into
like bad guys lair yeah what's he doing
he's sitting down playing mahjong with
his fellow with these guys asserting
dominance right those that's that's like
the image i have of mahjong like in that
that
dark smokey room and everything like
that well it's like i feel like it's
like the poker of japan or like poker of
asia really yeah definitely the kind of
game where gambling's not legal but me
and the boys can have a little wager or
two you know
yeah have you guys ever played bridge
before uh no i'm not 90. yeah exactly
i've heard of that game what is that
that that's that's a game which i don't
know like card game
it is a card game um i don't know what
the image is i don't know if it's like
famous outside of the uk or anything
like that oh yeah it's famous in the us
and again for being the thing that
people play and old people play it right
yeah and like i remember i think it was
in like high school or something um one
of our teachers for like uh for like
this uh for like you know you know you
have a free period sometimes and it's
the end of term you can do whatever you
like uh so this teacher decided to teach
us bridge
um just teach us the rules and i got
like i got like addicted at a point
where i'd like joined the bridge club
yes i i was [ __ ] i was that kid who
actually joined the bridge cup because
like it was he had this image of like
mahjong being what old retired people
play in retirement homes but like it is
fun as [ __ ] right like it's it's kind of
similar to mahjong in a sense where you
get given a bunch of you know
it is it is kind of like poker where it
is
luck based but it's also skill skill
based but what i found most interesting
to bridge is that it's it's a team game
right so the basic concept is before
each game you have a partner who sits
like opposite you right
and you basically have to make a bet
on
how many
how many points you'd be able to get in
the hand you're about to play so you're
like kind of communicating with your
partner and communicating and trying to
like
assess what everyone what everyone has
uh by the bets that they're placing and
i thought that was like
i think that's like super genius it's
basically like uno but before the uno
game starts you have to try and guess
what everyone else has you're working in
a team
and uh yeah like
like to me i wanted to talk about it
because like bridge has this image of
being a boring game that all people play
but i think it's like interesting as
[ __ ] and i haven't played bridge since i
was in school uh when i was in bridge
club but yeah i got super addicted for a
while because i i think it's a genuinely
fun game yeah it's the same with marjon
right i was like i i you know before i
started playing it i was like nah i'm
not going to get into this like this is
what my grandma was into yeah yeah yeah
it's like but then when you actually
start playing you realize just how like
intricate it is and it's not just like a
[ __ ] you know well i don't think it
was an old people thing i think it was
like a really complicated thing yeah but
it's it's interesting though how even
something like mahjong which is a very
complicated like deep you know
and very like you know
mind-intensive game yeah is associated
with all people yeah yeah if you look at
like the pro scene for example like most
people are like dudes and chicks yeah i
mean yeah i mean it's like you know it's
like
chess in
the parks in new york so yeah all the
old dudes are playing it but yeah it's
the young people here it's a pr thing
right when are we going to get like you
know a twitch camera everything
everything's a branding issue yeah yeah
because i i i can't be fixed with a bit
of branding and people remember like
like literally just two years ago where
chess had the same thing and then
suddenly chess had his [ __ ] second
renaissance uh with the explosion it's
had on twitch and now it's seen as like
this cool thing though mahjong's next
i'm going to call it mahjong is next you
know you know what i want to learn
already on that [ __ ] yeah yeah that
that's the secret we need to get the v
tubers to all start playing the japanese
the japanese youtubers have been on that
[ __ ] for so long yeah right yeah i think
yeah weirdly chess is one of those
sports where
when you look at it on paper it
shouldn't be a spectator sport yeah like
everything about it makes it
almost a bad spectator sport there's
long gaps in between moves yeah it's not
that
engaging
storylines are a little harder to
you know get across
and it's visually not that exciting it's
uh you look at a board for like 15
minutes at a time if you're lucky
they'll make a move every 15 minutes at
the world championship but somehow i
think just out of pure
like being a very solid and ubiquitous
game it's managed to somehow carve a
good niche and a pretty strong one yeah
but also chess has also had great
success by having the branding of being
the smart man's gear well the smartest
of smarts play chess
i think i think the problem with chess
as a spectator sport is that um with a
lot of sports right you you look at the
higher level players you look at you
know like you know traditional sports
like football basketball maybe even like
league or whatever and you can like
you can even
even as a normal person you can
appreciate the skill being shown you see
someone doing a speed run of mario 64 or
something you're like damn those are
some no words needed yeah no one is
needed that's [ __ ] speaks for itself
but like me watching
a high level chess game like the chess
world championships is like i've never
understood the feeling of that side
character in dragon ball z where like
the character explains the moves yeah
you know where we're like where like the
main characters are following the fight
perfectly and you just see like you just
see nothing like that this is me
watching high level chess you know
that's why i think chess has gotten
really good in recent uh years at having
the the kind of what a lot of esports
are doing and what traditional sports
are doing for a long time where one of
them is the one that's saying what's
going on and one of them's helping add
color and break it down and yeah like
explain it and chest has been really
good at that recently because i know i
like watching the world championships
but even then there are periods where
nothing happens for 20 minutes
like
[ __ ] to do like come on like yeah
sometimes i get like i i i get um
recommended like a clip of magnus
carlsen streaming or something like that
and it's just like an out of context
clip of like this [ __ ] 500 iq move
and then the move happens and i don't
even know it's happened yeah because it
was like five moves ago that he reacted
to it and like he and like i remember i
think one of the funniest videos i've
seen it's just like i can't remember the
exact video but it's uh it's a
it's a parody video of someone
commentating on a magnus carlsen stream
and it's just like a normal person
commenting on his stream and it's just
like and magnus carson leaves his night
hanging is he going to take it is the
opponent going to take it no he doesn't
take it he doesn't take the three nights
oh now he's left his queen hanging is he
is he gonna take the queen magnus the
queen is right there no he doesn't take
the queen and uh and he looks like he's
in an awful position right now and he
resigns magnus carlsen resigns i don't
know what's going on and it's just it's
it's it's it's exactly how i feel
watching yeah watching a high level
chess game when i'm just like there is a
hanging queen right there why is magnus
castle not taking the hanging oh and he
just resigned for no reason um he
scrolls to the comments section and it's
never the top comment that's explaining
what's happening it's always like buried
a few comments down just be like can
someone just explain to me what i
thought i just witnessed please
um but yeah i mean like that's why
one
one game i really want to get into
because it sounds super interesting it
always looks super interesting to me um
but i'm [ __ ] terrified of possibly
getting into is go go seems to me like
that is just like chess is complicated
by itself go
to me even just
even just the concept of go it seems
like what like viewing
a bottomless pit that you cannot see
like
my granddad was into go and he was like
really good at it and he tried to teach
me when i was in high school and i was
like i don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening i know you're like i know
you're showing me the ropes like really
nicely and clearly but like
i'm all i'm thinking is oh black and
white stones
all i know is that google's documentary
about the ai they built to beat the best
player yeah then i read hikaru ago and i
was like i understand what's happening
no i i i like because i also read hikaru
and ago as well i read all of it and i
remember there was a point where they
tried to explain what was going on to
the viewer and i think halfway through
the manga they just stopped yeah they
they just stopped showing the matches
right and they just like i'm not even
going to try and explain it this guy
wins and you see like it's a manga that
that just it bases its hype on of people
off of like character reactions yeah as
opposed to what's going on in the match
i think it's because they just assume
you're like you're you're you're feeling
full
you should know how this works by now
like we're not gonna explain it to you